>>Reto: Welcome to The App Clinic at the brand
new time of 10:30 AM, Mountain View time.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Reto: My name's Reto Meier.
>>Ian: And I'm still asleep.
[Reto laughs]
But if I were awake, I would be Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Reto: Excellent.
And today we're gonna take a look at photography
and camera apps in The App Clinic.
We've got a good
range of apps to look at.
In fact, these are them.
We've got EyeEm, PicsArt, Glimmr and Camera
Zoom FX.
>>Ian: I've really been looking forward to
these, Reto, 'cause I know we're both photographers,
or I should say you're a
photographer and I own a camera.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: I think it's probably fair to say
I also own a camera.
Actually, our erstwhile engineer, Mr. Daniel
Pham, is
probably--I think it's fair to say--a photographer.
>>Ian: That's quite true.
He takes all the pictures for our promotional
videos.
>>Reto: That's true.
And in fact, I was so confident in his ability
that the photos that we're gonna look at,
I actually
sent him around this morning with our demo
device to take some photos of stuff so we
would have some decent examples to
show people.
>>Ian: Excellent.
And just to be clear, our demo device today
is a Galaxy Nexus, right?
>>Reto: It is, indeed.
Yes.
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Dan: I don't wanna disappoint you guys,
but I really just took photos of the studio.
So, maybe the viewers will have a
good time looking at some behind the scenes
photos of how messy it really is in here.
>>Reto: Alright.
Well, I assume that they're gonna be highly
artistic and well-filtered photos of our studio.
So, I guess
we should kick off.
>>Ian: Alright.
Let's do it.
>>Reto: So, as per usual, we're gonna go through
each of the apps, give them a two to five
minute overview before having
a look at what we think the key is to making
a really great camera and photography app,
and some links to some developer
resources that should help you to be able
to take your app to that next level.
So let's start off with EyeEm.
And this is
a team that has actually worked with some
of our developer advocates over in London,
I think.
Rich Hyndman or Hyndman, or
however we have decided to say his name today
has been working with these guys and giving
them some advice.
So, let's
take a look and see how it looks.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
By the way, I noticed the QR codes are back.
Check that out.
>>Reto: Indeed.
>>Ian: Someone always complains when we don't
have the QR codes.
>>Reto: This is true.
>>Ian: Getting used to it now.
>>Reto: Yeah.
I've noticed that our Chroma Key is slightly
off as well.
So, we don't have quite the background that
we should
there, but--.
>>Ian: Oh, is that what happened?
I thought maybe you just chose to--
>>Reto: To leave it off?
>>Ian: get rid of the--.
>>Reto: No.
>>Ian: 'Cause Roman was, you know?
>>Reto: That's true.
But Roman is a trendsetter.
And I don't think I'm quite up to that level.
>>Ian: That's true.
We are always following Roman.
In fact, all I did--.
So, I did the intro video for today.
>>Reto: That was awesome by the way.
>>Ian: Thank you.
It's all Roman.
All Roman's artwork.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: Excellent.
So, if we can switch to the phone shot, we'll
take a look at--.
I can see it now.
There you go.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: So this is, this is Em.
So, we've, as you can see, folks, we have
removed the backwards facing camera and we're
doing HDMI.
Ooh, Chroma Key is almost right.
No.
Not gonna work.
>>Dan: Alright, guys.
I'm trying.
>>Reto: That's alright.
>>Ian: It's alright.
It's beautiful.
>>Reto: We'll let you continue to do that.
So, but what you've got up here is EyeEm.
So what it is, is basically what
you'd expect.
It's an app which lets you take photographs.
It lets you apply filters to them.
And it has a community for
sharing those photos with your friends, I
think particularly on Twitter and Facebook.
It's got the links for that
directly.
So you can see here, your front page is basically
what you would expect.
It's a rolling list view of all of the
photos that your friends have taken.
And one of the things which they've done quite
well here is they've got these tabs,
these tab labels that you can see here.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: And so, as people are tagging them,
you can go, "Oh, actually I'd be interested
to see more photos from Sam
Benedetto del Tronto."
You click that and it will take you to a bunch
of other things--show you on a map where it's
at and all the other photos by him.
>>Ian: Oh, that's very cool, yeah.
>>Reto: I quite like that.
So, this passes a big test of mine, which
is "can you get lost in the app?"
Are you gonna
spend a lot of time going, "Oh, cool.
I wanna see more of those sorts of photos
from those sorts of people."
One of the
really key features of this app, which I really
wanted to highlight, is they've done a really
good job on the UI of the
actual picture display.
You can see here they've got this heterogeneous
list view, or grid view I suppose it is.
>>Ian: Mm-hmm.
>>Reto: And you can see here, we've got different
sized images all coming together to create
something which is quite
compelling to look at.
And again, you can click through to each of
these.
>>Ian: Right.
Now this isn't a particularly well-accelerated
list view, though.
It feels a little janky.
>>Reto: It's a little janky, yeah.
Absolutely.
>>Ian: I'll say that's one thing.
So, Dan Galpin's actually been working for
about a year on some new techniques for
doing faster list view rendering for photos.
And hopefully one of these days, he'll actually
get that released.
>>Reto: That's right.
Yeah.
This is a nice shot.
This is the Googleplex.
Although, it says Googleplex 46.
It's not.
It's
Googleplex 44.
>>Ian: Right.
And in fact, we are in the room just above
the honeycomb.
>>Reto: That's right.
Just here.
We're in here.
So you can wave to us.
If you're here at the right time, we would
love to
have people holding signs outside the window.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: That would be cool.
>>Ian: We're on the second floor, so that
would be insanely cool if they were right
outside the window.
>>Reto: What?
You think our fans don't own ladders?
Do you think they don't have the dedication
it takes?
>>Ian: I assume they own jetpacks.
>>Reto: Do you think that we don't have fans?
Hmm.
It could be a problem.
Anyway.
>>Ian: So, I'll tell you the first thing that
strikes me about this app is this button down
here.
It looks like maybe
that's how I'm gonna take a picture.
>>Reto: It is.
>>Ian: OK.
And you can see, I think if you're on a different
phone, maybe a Galaxy S2 or something, you
would think this
is a pretty cool design.
Once you get onto one of these no-button phones,
you realize this is actually kind of a bad
idea.
>>Reto: It's very close, very, very close
to your 'home' button.
>>Ian: Yeah.
It's very close to the 'home' button.
It's very similar to the action that you're
gonna use to bring up
Google Now.
There's a lot of things that you can screw
up with the camera button here.
And that's, as we've mentioned
before, that's one of the reasons that we
discourage tabs on the bottom because you
can very easily get mixed up with
that bottom row of buttons.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: So.
And, of course, they do also have a 'menu'
button down here, which is--.
>>Reto: And this is the confusing thing because
they have something which looks a lot like
an action bar which has a
'menu' button.
And if you click that, you do get an overflow
menu.
And so they've done this thing where you've
still got
the 'menu' button and that brings up the drop
down.
>>Ian: I wonder if they're using something
like Action Bar Sherlock and then they're
not setting the API level high
enough.
Because we actually don't document this correctly.
It's changed since the Docs were released.
You can't absolutely guarantee that that thing
will go away until your API level is 15.
>>Reto: Yeah, right.
>>Ian: And we had originally said all that.
>>Reto: Yeah.
So, make sure it's up to it.
I thought 14, but let's make it 15 and just
be safe.
>>Ian: Mm-hmm.
>>Reto: So, that's one thing.
You can get rid of that really easily 'cause
it'll come back for devices which don't have,
which do have hard 'menu' button.
>>Ian: OK.
>>Reto: So the other call-out that I wanted
to mention here is that they have implemented
the Draw Pattern.
And I'm pretty
sure they're aware that this isn't quite the
right Draw Pattern, but I wanted to put it
out there for other people who
may be watching.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: So, this is following that prototype
G+ model where the action bar all shifts across
and you can see that here.
So, everything's moved across.
The right model is actually the way YouTube
does it, which is that your action bar is
consistent.
So all of the--oops--all the stuff here along
your action bar, this should stay here no
matter what.
And
rather than having a draw icon, you would
have your application icon or logo with an
up affordance.
So then, clicking
that will then leave everything here as it
is and then just have this side part here
slide out.
So in the same way, but
still having the action bar along the top.
And I think, so that's the right way to do
it.
And that's all listed in the
design patterns on Android design.
>>Ian: Yeah.
And again, it's not that these guys got it
wrong.
It's that there wasn't a design pattern.
Now there is.
>>Reto: [chuckles] If they followed an example,
which turns out we decide it wasn't quite
the right example.
>>Ian: Alright.
So, I'll tell you this is driving me crazy
'cause I'll tell you.
So, we have two options.
You can scoot
over or we can move the camera.
>>Reto: I can scoot.
>>Ian: OK.
Wow.
Reto does not want to move the camera I think.
>>Reto: Leave the camera alone, Ian.
>>Ian: Yeah, exactly.
I fixed it last week and now it's back up
and not fixed again.
>>Dan: Hey, guys.
Please don't touch my stuff.
>>Ian: Alrighty.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: So otherwise, things here work as
you'd expect.
You have the ability to 'like'.
A nice little animation comes up
there.
You can add comments.
They've got a pretty custom UI here with their
own custom buttons, but it's consistent
throughout.
There's a color scheming.
There's a design ethos here, which I think
works.
It passes the--.
Is it different?
Yeah.
Does it look good?
Yes.
Let's try the share here.
>>Ian: What I probably would've liked to see,
what--?
>>Reto: Standard share intent.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Probably would've liked to see the actual
'share' button.
>>Reto: That's true.
>>Ian: That's something that I think people
are getting used to.
And as we use that more, it becomes a consistent
way to
say "I want to share something that's agnostic
to services or what's hot this week."
I think we've said it before.
If
this phone had been designed five years ago,
everybody would have MySpace buttons.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
[chuckles]
>>Ian: And we'd all feel like fools, wouldn't
we?
The other thing is, what is flag?
>>Reto: I think for inappropriate things.
>>Ian: Oh, I see.
Gotcha.
OK.
Flag it for nudity, yeah.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: There is a naked Android right there.
Yeah, and I love this, the animation that
you got to work that I can't.
>>Reto: This is the problem when you have
touch targets which are less than 48 pixels.
People have trouble hitting them.
>>Ian: Small-fingered Reto wins again.
>>Reto: Boom.
>>Ian: So, the only thing that I miss is I
feel like I'd like to see that carried out
everywhere.
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Ian: It's always so sad when you see a beautiful
user interface and it's been lovingly crafted
and then you get to the
point where like, the world ends and everything
stops and you realize they ran out of time
and it's just a normal Android
system dialog.
And it's not just Android that does this.
I've got plenty of apps on my PC that do this,
but I think that
especially for an app like this it's all about
beauty.
It's worth taking the extra time to make sure
that the entire
interface follows whatever design theme you've
chosen, whether that's the stock Android design
or something completely
different.
>>Reto: Alright.
So, let's have a quick look at the photo-taking
functionality before moving on.
So we'll start using the
camera 'cause otherwise it starts to get a
little bit confusing.
Oh, yeah it does work.
Nice.
>>Ian: Oh, wow.
That's awesome.
[pause]
>>Reto: Boom.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: That's a winner.
That's your new--.
>>Ian: That's my new album cover.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
I guess that's a tick.
>>Ian: No, it's just a mole.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: And so we can go through here and
apply all of the usual hipster filters.
Let's see if we can make you even more
jaundiced 'cause I think that's kind of awesome.
There we go.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: That's a win.
So, what you'd expect except that it stopped
there.
So, that's a bug.
Let's report that to the guys
so that they--.
>>Ian: That could be any number of things.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: What build are you running on this?
>>Reto: Whatever the latest public release
is.
>>Ian: The stock retail?
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Alright.
>>Reto: So, let's move on.
So, that's EyeEm.
>>Ian: Awesome.
>>Reto: A really popular app.
Got a lot of great comments on the moderator
link for that one.
So, we will be returning to
this later on when we look at the prescriptions
for a great app.
But definitely a good start.
>>Ian: Let's take a look at PicsArts.
>>Reto: Let's.
Loading PicsArt.
Alright.
Let's open that up.
So, right off the bat, we get the 'follow
us on Twitter.'
This doesn't come up every time the activity
launches, but it comes up often enough to
be a pain, particularly 'cause all
you have there is a 'follow' button.
And you can hit back to cancel it, but we're
kind of anti-dialogs to begin with.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: And we're anti forcing people to do
things to help verify your own brand.
"Go rate me in the Store five stars,"
that sort of thing.
And "Follow us on Twitter?"
By all means have a Twitter account which
people can follow for news, but
trying to force them to do so?
It's overly attached girlfriend being.
It's like, "Follow me."
No.
This isn't cool.
Like,
people will find it.
Make it easy for them to do it, but you don't
need quite that much validation.
>>Ian: Yeah, actually, yeah.
It is a little desperate.
OK, so they've got this nice like, what do
you call this?
It's
like a city UI or some sort of urban UI.
>>Reto: I guess, yeah.
Suburban area UI, something like that.
>>Ian: Yeah.
So, it's an interesting pattern.
I probably would have maybe taken out some
of these.
>>Reto: It makes it kind of busy.
There's a lot going on there.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: It reminds me a little of--.
It's a shop.
That's interesting.
>>Ian: But in general, really nice.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: I mean, the colors are nice and bright.
>>Reto: It's got an appealing look.
>>Ian: Yeah.
OK.
So, what can you do with PicsArt?
>>Reto: What can you do?
So, let's have a flick through.
So basically, it's, no data?
That's just nice.
So, basically
it's a combination of a few different kinds
of camera apps.
So you can take your photos and apply hipster
filters.
[Ian sneezes]
>>Ian: Excuse me.
>>Reto: Which we'll do.
Once again, let's try and get--.
>>Ian: Let's get Dan.
Yeah.
[pause]
>>Reto: There we go.
Very nice.
So you can take your photos and apply your
hipster filters as you would normally expect.
And it's got a good selection of you know,
different standard things.
And you can actually do quite a lot here in
terms of applying different kinds of presets.
Eventually.
Maybe.
>>Ian: It does seem to be taking a long time
but I do like their little rotating status
bar.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: Well, and this is one of those things
too, where they're obviously not using the
stock Android art but it is part of their
branding.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: And you know, I know we harp on this
a lot but we get this question a lot, you
know people bring us an app that uses some-
Let's call a spade a spade, sometimes they'll
pull in assets directly from the iPhone-
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: - or Windows Mobile.
And they'll say, well, that's just the way
our designers like it.
And I think that's not really cool.
I mean first off, it's not Android but second
off, it's not yours.
It's somebody else's stuff.
>>Reto: That's right.
>>Ian: But when you take something that Android
provides and then make it completely yours,
so it works exactly the same, you know has
the little cycling colors so that you know
what's going on but has your branding in it?
I think that's great.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: I wish that more apps would do that.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
And then you get the advantage of having that
consistency across all the versions of your
app and everything else.
>>Ian: Now we also have the very consistent--.
You know, this should be a built in control
right now-
>>Reto: You're right.
>>Ian: -the hipster strip.
>>Reto: And they've actually got like a bunch
of different ones.
So they've got the standard effects that you're
applying there.
And you can actually modify the degree of
each of these which is nice as well.
Let's see, apply that and then I think you
can go through and apply a bunch of different
kind of filters.
So they've got the distortion filters, they've
got you know all those different things.
>>Ian: I think it's really interesting that
compared to some of the other apps that we've
looked at, this app is really slow at applying
filters and I wonder if it's because they're
not taking advantage of acceleration.
In Android, especially in Honeycomb and above,
you can use RenderScript or you can use the
GPU to accelerate this sort of thing.
And this is- most of these filters just boil
down to convolutions of one kind or another.
So you can- and Java is just not good at convolutions
at all.
Its memory layout is wrong, it doesn't have
access to SIMD floating point instructions.
I don't even think it has access in non-strict
floating point instructions which means you're
gonna be abiding by IEEE standards and getting
into all sorts of performance problems.
So you really, really, really don't want to
write your filter code in Java or even in
just generic C++, you really wanna be using
NEON or- for the best compatibility actually
just write it in OpenGL.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
So let's um- we'll click through.
So we've all seen this sort of thing beforehand,
so if you hit OK then you have a bunch of
options.
You can upload it to PicsArts, save it to
the SD card, Tweet it, export it a whole bunch
of things.
Now, personally I would kind of prefer if
it just did something sensible by default.
Maybe save it to the SD card and then take
me back to a page where it just displays all
the things that I've saved and allow me to
share or add to a timeline or whatever from
there.
Rather than asking for this explicit thing.
>>Ian: Well and this- it seems like a lot
of people get this wrong.
In a mobile app- and Reto you had a great
talk about this at Google I/O, you have the
opportunity to make your app work like magic.
Forget about saving and loading and knowing
what file paths are and all sorts of things
like that.
If you look at good mobile apps, they just
always work.
They do what the user probably wants and they
give the user a way to back out if it's not
what they wanted.
So, it shouldn't be about saving, it should
be about deleting things that have already
been saved because everything gets saved.
>>Reto: Exactly.
You know, you don't have this problem anymore
where you've got a totally really, really
limited amount of storage and one or two extra
photos are gonna kill you.
You can take a lot of photos before it's a
problem.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: You know back in the day where, you
know back in the DOS days where the only thing
you had to identify a file was its filename
and its extension and so then you had to create
these complex hierarchical folder structures
in order to be able to find anything.
So you're basically creating metadata out
of a file system.
These days you can use the metadata, you can
display the photos you can do all that stuff.
>>Ian: I dare say almost no one knows or cares
what the file names are for their photos now.
>>Reto: Exactly.
Particularly not on your mobile where- see
this is all a little bit confusing.
See I've already saved it and just took me
back here-
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: So I'm just gonna hit close and assume
it's kept it somewhere.
>>Ian: Good luck.
>>Reto: Yeah.
So then it takes us back to the photos, we
can continue taking photos or hit back again-
>>Ian: So they've done their own kind of camera
view, too.
>>Reto: They have.
So, they've done it completely from scratch.
>>Ian: That one- Yeah I'm not as excited about
this just because I feel like this isn't quite
as much their branding.
I mean, I look at these icons and I'm like
yeah I think I've seen those somewhere before.
>>Reto: Yeah and they're really small-
>>Ian: They really are.
>>Reto: -and they're not particularly high
res either.
I can see a little bit of mess around some
of the vector art.
>>Ian: Well, Galaxy Nexus is always a good
test case for finding out if you've got the
right resources because it's a 720p phone.
And same thing for I think Galaxy s3, Galaxy
s2 are the same resolution.
So it's an extremely high resolution display
and if you're just thinking to yourself, "oh
these things look good on a four inch display"
that's not always true if you're on this-
one of these xhdpi devices.
>>Reto: So the other little thing I want to
point real quick is that you're hiding my
status bar which is pain.
Because we've now been going on for 15 minutes
about this app and I don't know-so please
don't, please, please I beg of you, do not
hide my status bar.
I want to know what time it is, I wanna to
see my emails coming in.
That is actually more important than your
app.
>>Ian: If you must hide the status bar at
least let me tap and get it back.
>>Reto: Something to get it back.
Yeah.
Like it's fine if you've got like a gallery
view and I wanna look at my photos in fullscreen
and flick through it, sure.
But you know, give me that tap ability to
get things back.
>>Ian: Yeah, couple apps that do this really
well are the ereaders, so Google Play Books,
Amazon Kindle.
Both have really good status bar hiding and
showing functionality.
>>Reto: Yeah.
See if we can get data, so I don’t know
if we- apparently can.
OK so we've got some here.
So we can see this is the community aspect
of it.
This is less janky in terms of the scroll
but we're still seeing a reasonable amount
of time taken to load each of the pictures
here.
>>Ian: Well, it's tough to get around that
because we've got network latency, we’ve
got the decoding.
These are probably not small bitmaps.
>>Reto: And that's kinda the question here,
is that-
>>Ian: And you can see actually once things
end in cache.
>>Reto: So the caching is good.
It's keeping them there, which is nice.
>>Ian: I think of the apps that I've looked
at, these guys are doing exactly the right
thing.
>>Reto: That's right.
>>Ian: You can't overcome the laws of physics,
but-
>>Reto: Really?
Or are you just not trying hard enough?
>>Ian: Yeah, well.
They're trying pretty hard actually.
This-
>>Reto: No, it does look pretty good.
[unintelligible]
>>Ian: it's very hard to see on the video,
on YouTube but this is an extremely smooth
scrolling experience.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: The flinging is just right-
>>Reto: It's got the right physics, yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, it's all good.
So, Bravo.
>>Reto: And you click through, and so this
is a good experience.
You're swiping, swipe left right and you can
see here the physics are right.
It's moving at the same speed as my finger
but then I can just do a quick flick and it
feels about right.
So they've done a good job.
>>Ian: And they've got the pinch to zoom.
And then it's always an interesting question
what do you do once you've pinched to zoom-
>>Reto: And get to the edge.
>>Ian: But this seems fine.
>>Reto: I like that.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: I like the idea of once I get to the
edge of the picture – as long as I'm able
to take it back and undo my swipe across,
I think that's the right approach.
>>Ian: I'm actually wondering if there's any
chance that these guys are actually using
Dan Galpin's library because it does exactly
this.
[Reto laughs]
>>Ian: That is exactly this behavior.
>>Reto: Possibly.
Or Dan's maybe seen this and used it as a
basis.
>>Ian: Quite possibly.
Yeah.
But yeah I think that these guys are doing
everything right as far as- the physics there
are a little bit-
>>Reto: It gets a little funny once you're
bouncing off the edge.
>>Ian: wheeee wheeee
>>Reto: That's too much fun for this time
of day.
And again we've kinda got the- this is interesting.
So now we've got the menu button on the action
bar here, but they've still got legacy button
down here and that does absolutely nothing.
So that's now confusing because it's ambiguous.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: So at the very least, I mean really
the right solution here is get rid of this.
Set your target SDK to 15.
You know, at the very least.
>>Ian: Or set it to 16 now.
>>Reto: Yeah, exactly.
It should always be the latest version, that's
a good tip for you guys as well.
Always tie with the latest SDK, there's really
no reason not to.
It voids your app.
>>Ian: Well the only possible reason not to
is if you have no confidence that your app
works on the latest SDK and you're unable
to test on any new device or new emulator.
>>>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: So I would have sympathy with, let's
say hard core video apps-
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Ian: - that are trying to do streaming that's
only been supported recently.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: And is still a little buggy.
But in general, your UI should support the
latest SDK app.
>>Reto: Alright, so let's jump out of this
cause I'm not actually sure how much time
we've spent.
But let's have a look at Glimmr.
So Glimmr's a little bit different.
This is not a sort of standard camera replacement
app.
This is actually a app to browse Flickr.
So, in terms of functionality, much more simplistic
here, you basically sign into your Flickr
account and then you can scroll all the pictures.
>>Ian: Nice.
What does Daniel Pham have to say about ricers?
[laughter]
>>Dan: It was like that, alright?
>>Reto: Yeah, looks like you know how to party.
>>Dan: That was actually at I/O last year,
not this year but-
>>Ian: Yeah, cause this year it was Train
and nobody was partying.
>>Dan: Yeah, I was close enough to Dave Navarro's
leg to almost reach out and grab him.
Decided that that was probably not a good
idea.
>>Reto: You decided that was probably be a
problem considering the restraining order.
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Right, well yeah.
So for those of you who didn't make it to
I/O-
>>Reto: This is what it looked like.
>>Ian: -feast your eyes on some of these shots.
>>Reto: There's Mr. Galpin.
>>Ian: Oh yeah, without his beard.
>>Reto: Beardless Galpin.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: That's a little scary.
>>Ian: It is.
[silly voice] The Master is having a party
tonight.
>>Reto: Overall, it's a nice effect, again
you've got the nice smooth swiping between
items.
You've got the standard action bar along the
top here which behaves in the way that it
should.
You've got the refresh icon which works in
place.
Again probably no need for an explicit refresh
as a primary action just because your photos
aren't going to be updating that quickly.
You can probably get away with coming up with
some sort of sensible refresh model.
>>Ian: Now you know what I love about this
app?
>>Reto: Please.
>>Ian: This page right here.
This is exactly what a photos oriented list
view should look like.
>>Reto: Right.
>>Ian: Look at this they've done a great job-
>>Reto: It's all images.
>>Ian: It's all images.
They've overlaid text that looks nice, it's
big enough, it's readable.
Now, one thing that I haven't seen, I haven’t
seen any photo that is just really really
bad for text.
Well, there's one.
>>Reto: Yeah, but you can see that they-
>>Ian: But you can see that yeah, they've
overlaid some – it could be a little darker
on this one.
Exactly.
That's the whole idea really.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: You make the photo everything.
Don’t put little drop shadows behind it,
don't put bars between it, don't shrink the
photo down so it's thumbnail sized.
This just looks beautiful.
>>Reto: Exactly, I mean there's all kinds
of things here and straight away you can see
where- you can tell from a photo even from
this relatively small portion of it, whether
it's going to be something you're interested
in exploring more of-
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: -and I think they've done a great
job there.
>>Ian: The only disappointing thing is it
feels like their caching isn't quite as good
as the last app.
>>Reto: No, you can see here, as soon as you
sort of get more than sort of half a swipe
beyond the page you're looking at, you've
got the white screen.
>>Ian: That is understandable though, the
view pager is sort of set up to do that.
And you have to really go out of your way
to do cache management, if you want to serve
lots and lots of images very quickly.
>>Reto: Yeah.
And one thing you can do as well which maybe
at issue here, make sure you're downloading
different sized images as well.
So obviously you're going to have the double
hit if you click on it and then you have to
download the full sized image.
But at least you're dealing with a smaller
memory footprint, faster downloads, faster
load times, those sorts of things.
>>Ian: Now right after that, all the sudden
I'm sort of disappointed because-
>>Reto: Ahh, you're back into text mode.
>>Ian: Right.
Right.
>>Reto: That's a shame.
>>Ian: Well, I mean this is for your Flickr
groups, I guess, and obviously the photos
are maybe less important but I would argue
that- if it were linked in, I'd be like, yeah
photos whatever.
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Ian: It's Flickr.
>>Reto: It's Flickr.
>>Ian: You're not there for anything else.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So it feels like you could do the same thing
here where you're just taking that image associated
with the group, make that your full background.
And then maybe because there's more text and
it's more important you overlay more of that
on top of the text.
But when you've got images, like you know
look at the way magazines work.
The big advantage of magazines is that you've
got rich color, full color and with apps like
this if you have the pictures, use them.
The pictures are awesome.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
Yeah.
>>Reto: So this is looking pretty good.
We don't have the hipster filters to go through
so I think maybe we'll move onto the next
app.
The last one which we're gonna look at today.
Which is Camera ZOOM FX.
>>Ian: Camera Zoom.
>>Reto: So this is just your hipster filters.
It's locked into landscape view which we decided
to leave this way to kinda prove a point which
is I don't want to always take my photos in
landscape view.
>>Ian: True.
>>Reto: So your UI particularly you can see
here this is basically an entirely custom
camera UI.
They've drawn all that themselves.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: So there's really no reason here why
they can't rotate the assets, right?
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Reto: And even these days- I remember back
in the days of Android 1.1, you had to take
photos in landscape mode because there was
no way of knowing what orientation the camera
was at.
That changed a long time ago now so you can
actually query the device to find out what
orientation of the camera is and rotate things
so that they're sort of in the right aspect
ratio and perspective.
>>Ian: It's also worth asking yourself if
you really, really need to do a custom camera
view because-
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: -whenever you duplicate system functionality,
you risk looking out of date once the system
updates.
And, in particular, you're going to miss out
on any brand new functionality-
>>Reto: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>>Ian: -that the new system gives you.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: Now for this, you know maybe they've
got some really cool camera stuff going on.
The problem is that a lot of the coolest camera
technology in Android is being supplied by
OEM libraries so, you may be missing out on
something really, really slick if you completely
override the camera.
>>Reto: That's interesting, if I hit front
facing it doesn't do anything.
So, it may be a bug.
>>Ian: Well, that's what you get right?
>>Reto: It's certainly freezing.
>>Ian: Did it just freeze, you think?
>>Reto: No, it's back.
>>Ian: OK
>>Reto: It seems to just take a while.
>>Ian: So the only reason I can think of that
you'd want to build a custom camera and do
the preview yourself is if you really need
to do live preview.
So do these guys do live preview?
>>Reto: I believe that they do, yeah if you
hit the- if you start it up and hit the FX
button I believe that it will apply-
[pause]
>>Ian: K.
>>Reto: Let's have a look.
>>Ian: Alright, let's see this is coloring
or-
>>Reto: Branding effects.
>>Ian: Alright.
Oh here, vignette.
Vignette's always good.
There it is.
>>Reto: Yeah, there you go, so they're applying
that in real time, you can see that on the
edge there.
>>Ian: Right.
But, you'll notice that a lot of the effects
that you want are actually disabled in the
real time mode.
>>Reto: In the real time mode, yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, which isn't surprising.
It's actually, in ICS we improved things,
in Jelly Bean we improved them even more,
I think there's one extra step that the GL
team is talking about.
But we've systematically been reducing the
number of operations that it takes to do a
live preview with effects.
So, originally it was extremely tedious and
you had to bring things through Java.
>>Reto: Mmhmm.
>>Ian: Now there's a single copy involved
if you're doing the GPU acceleration on your
effects.
>>Reto: Mmhmm.
>>Ian: And in the future at some point, we
don't know exactly when, but the team thinks
that they can get that down to zero copies.
So, you'll be able to go directly from the
camera to the GPU to whatever without passing
through user mode code at all.
>>Reto: Yeah, that's excellent.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: In fact, the app which I've seen which
really does the most intensive real-time effects
is I think Paper Camera?
They do a pretty good job of this.
>>Ian: Yeah, they really do.
>>Reto: they have quite most of their effects
at runtime which is kinda nice.
>>Ian: Yep, and they've done a lot of work
to make that successful.
>>Reto: I'm not surprised.
So that's basically the way this app works
and it's got all of the standard filters that
you'd expect and you can apply them to photos
either from the camera or from your gallery
as well which is nice.
There's no sort of community picture viewing
sharing functionality built in, at least not
that I could find.
>>Ian: That's a shame because the share intent
is really really easy to do and it works well
for photos.
>>Reto: Well share they've got, so they've
got the standard share intent.
>>Ian: Oh OK, so you're just saying that they
don't hook into a-
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: -like a Flickr client.
>>Reto: Like I start it up for the first time
and I can't flick through and look at other
photos that people have taken and shared and
that sort of thing.
Which makes a app like Instagram a big part
of that.
>>Ian: I'm kinda on the fence about that.
>>Reto: Really?
>>Ian: Because on the one hand I'm like, yeah,
you're right, every time I pick up an app
like it's really cool.
On the other hand I'm like well, gee, don't
I have social networks for that?
>>Reto: Yeah, it's true it's true.
But you know, I kinda like the combination
particularly if it's not- if the community
is really simplified, so it's not about anything
other than taking a photo and letting other
people see it.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: Cause then you kinda get that experience
of being able to interact and share with people
who, you know, are using the same app, taking
the same sorts of photos, I think it adds
something to it.
>>Ian: I think you're right.
>>Reto: OK, cool.
So that's- now see and again we're hiding
the status bar.
Please stop hiding the status bar.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: I beg you.
>>Ian: Just make sure you have a way to get
back, that's so important.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: Because here's the thing, let's say
I am completely immersed in your app and let's
say I'm also an adult with responsibilities,
if I can get back to the status bar I can
find out what time it is, I can respond to
a notification, I can check my calendar, I
can do all these things.
If not, then I have to leave your app anytime
my phone beeps, which is annoying.
>>Reto: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: Because some notifications I literally
do not care about-
>>Reto: No.
>>Ian: -but I don’t know until I've looked
at the status bar.
>>Reto: That's right.
And you know, if you're doing a show like
this you need to know what time it is to see
if you're massively over time.
Which we always are.
>>Ian: We're not.
>>Reto: But at least we're not actually past
the end time of our show yet, which is, which
is nice.
>>Ian: That's quite true.
>>Reto: So let's have a look.
So we've had-
>>Ian: I've been actively sabotaging the show
as we go on, you're carefully-
>>Reto: [unintelligible]
>>Ian: Yeah, OK, let's talk about-
>>Reto: We've both been sabotaging.
>>Ian: -what are the prescriptions for apps?
>>Reto: Indeed.
So these are the things we're looking for
having browsed through a bunch of these apps.
The things that we've found which makes them
good.
You know, we always say that you can't contradict
the design guide and that certainly still
holds here but I think one additional thing
that we want to note is that it should really
look good.
These are apps which are targeted at people
who like the way things look; photographers,
design folks, hipsters.
It's really important that you create something
that's immediately appealing and you can see
that at the beginning when I showed you the
feature graphics, and I meant to point it
out at the time but completely forgot to.
They all have feature graphics; they're all
really compelling-
>>Ian: Yeah, really really pretty.
>>Reto: -highly saturated images which look
great.
And so that's the same sort of thing you want
here, you want to make sure the entire process
is appealing.
Similarly you want to make sure that the app
works on every image in the gallery and at
the same time works on devices without the
camera.
So for most of these apps, they allow you
to add effects both to live photos on the
camera and to things you already have on your
phone.
And so I want that to work on anything I can
pick from the Picasa gallery or from the phone
gallery.
And similarly I want it to work on my Galaxy
Nexus, I'm sorry on my Nexus 7, even though
it has no rear facing camera, I'm not going
to use it to take photos but I have all of
my Picasa gallery images synced to it, so
maybe I want to apply all these filters on
a bigger screen.
It should let me do that.
>>Ian: Or you wanna just browse your friends'
photos.
>>Reto: Exactly.
[unintelligible]
>>Ian: That's actually one of the biggest
problems that we had when we introduced Nexus
7 was photography apps that just assumed that
if you didn't have a camera you wouldn't be
interested in a photo app and that's just
not true.
>>Reto: Exactly.
And obviously you want to have the standard
and some unique hipster filters which I think
most of the apps which we looked at today,
actually managed to do.
>>Ian: To me, it's not just about hipster
filters, it's about ways to make the photo
look good.
So even if you have really unique filters,
one thing that I think the most successful
apps do is a little bit of automatic tweaking,
behind the scenes, maybe even without telling
the user.
So maybe just a little bit of auto level balance,
auto white balance to try and make the photos
look good.
>>Reto: Absolutely, I mean that's the thing
we all know that we're not expecting to be
able to take great photos with our camera
phones off the bat.
It's not an SLR, you can't tweak all of your
manual settings and get it just so.
So you're looking to concentrate on making
sure you're getting a good shot, good angles,
good framing and all that sort of stuff.
And then having the software help you make
it look like something that really represents
it well.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Reto: So let's give you some tips.
The first tip here is on using the camera,
so you've got two options here which we saw
both of which is either an app which uses
a completely custom UI which is what Camera
ZOOM FX have done here so you get that completely
custom camera user interface which I can't
find.
Let's see, save and close, again save button,
so here you've got the completely custom camera
user interface.
And I think the first app that we looked at,
Eyeme-
>>Ian: By the way, I think that where we're
seeing save, the correct verbiage to use is
done.
That's not a verb, but that's the label you
should be using.
Because there is a case for having this intermediate-
like we've talked about this with alarm apps.
There is an intermediate stage where you are
working on something and you don’t really
feel complete.
You don’t feel- like when I'm setting my
alarm I'm doing the hours, I haven't done
the minutes yet.
If it just- if I got a phone call then and
my alarm got saved in that state, that would
not make me happy.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: Likewise when I'm applying filters
and doing a lot of tweaking, you want to have
sort of a commit step but you shouldn't call
it save.
>>Reto: No.
>>Ian: Cause that doesn't make any sense.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: You should be saving as you go along.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Because even though the user hasn't
committed they still don’t want to lose
work, but you do want to get to a point where
you can roll back essentially.
>>Reto: Yeah, particularly when you're applying
filters like this it's all logical operations,
it's all maths right?
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: So while you don’t want to have
to keep each of those operations for every
photo, once you're done, you're done.
But in terms of being able to save your progress
even before you permanently alter the image,
you can just keep a track of exactly which
effects, which filters have been applied,
save that and then you can always reapply
it if they come back to the app after your
process has been killed.
>>Ian: Right, so you should always be prepared
for interruptions even interruptions that
happen at a very inconvenient time for you.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Ian: But you should never ask the user to
manage storage, to do anything but commit
an action that's already in progress.
>>Reto: Anytime you want to surprise a user
is with delight, not with annoyance.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Reto: So this is Eyeme and you can see that
when you hit the camera button it goes to
the basically to the built in camera.
So this using all of the functionality that
you would have on the standard built camera
app and then you can take a photo and then
it lets you retake or cancel or whatever you
want to do.
So that's your two approaches and both of
those described in the link down there in
the camera topic of the Android developer
guides.
So they will tell you how to use both approaches.
Let's have a look, so the other thing we talked
about what conforming to the design guide.
And so again we kind of have a few different
approaches here with these apps and I think
they've pretty much all, except for Glimmr
done some form of sort of custom user interface.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: And I think that's alright in this
circumstance it kinda makes sense.
When you have a particular ethos, a design
ethos which you want to be consistent with
on these apps, there were a few little bits
and pieces that- Eyeme I think is my favorite
look and feel in that it feels the most consistent
the most strongly branded.
And they've done a decent job, they need to
get rid of the legacy menu button down here,
they need to make the draw conform to our
new guidelines.
The search here you should probably be using
the- so this is a little weird here where
it goes off into its own search.
This should really just be using a standard
action bar search.
>>Ian: That's always annoying.
Yeah.
>>Reto: That should just be-
>>Ian: I think you know to a certain extent
that's our fault, these guys have obviously
tried to mimic the action bar pattern but
since our action bar support library is still
not done-
>>Reto: It makes it hard.
>>Ian: It's tough.
>>Reto: But that's something definitely something
to keep in mind and something to look for,
wherever you see sort of these standard patterns,
and I have to admit, we tend to have a different
view on what a standard pattern is based on
the fact that we're always using the latest
versions of the phones and the operating system.
>>Ian: That is true.
>>Reto: For us it's like well I've seen that
appropriate search action bar thing for like
a year, why is it taking people so long?
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Reto: So yeah, bear with us.
But particularly for these guys and for other
people sort of implementing these sorts of
patterns, you want search to be simple is
kind of the key element here.
Right now search is one, two, three-
>>Ian: Yikes.
>>Reto: -type, four-
>>Ian: And you know what's terrible, too,
is that it even looks like you should be able
to type into that right?
It looks like something-
>>Reto: It's the faux action bar.
The faux search bar.
>>Ian: Mean and horrible.
>>Reto: And so you know, if you take the alternative
approach based on the standard sort of action
bar version is that you will have one button
here and that'll expand and then you type
and then you hit enter and you're done.
So it's sort of only a couple of actions and
you straight away have it.
And if you do it that way, it will build your
search into a bunch of ways which will make
it easy for you to leverage that across the
system.
>>Ian: Yeah.
Once again, the feel that I get from this
app is that it had some good people behind
it-
>>Reto: Definitely.
>>Ian: Some really good design and they ran
out of time and I can tell you exactly where
on every piece of the UI exactly where they
ran out of time and decided, screw it, we're
gonna ship anyway.
>>Reto: That may well be the case.
In fact, you know we got I think a fair amount
of response from the Developers Strike Back
show just yesterday.
So we're going to invite the guys from Eyeme
to join us next Thursday and see if they can
use a bit of feedback on exactly at which
point they got to before they decided they
had to ship it.
>>Ian: You know what?
Shipping stuff before it's done is for Microsoft
Program Managers.
Don't be that guy.
>>Reto: [laughs] Don't be that guy.
Alright, so I think all of the apps did pretty
good so that's I think that's something which
was custom designed which looked pretty good.
>>Ian: I should mention by the way that I
did work for Microsoft, I'm not just slagging
off on them.
>>Reto: Slagging off the competitor for fun,
no you've been there.
You've done that job.
>>Ian: That's right.
>>Reto: You've been that guy.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: And so this is kind of the other approach.
So you're looking at Camera FX here and that
again is totally custom but I feel like here,
it's not really adding to it.
It makes it a little bit harder to navigate,
harder to understand what's going on and for
not a huge amount of gain.
This doesn’t look incredible.
>>Ian: Those touch targets are tiny.
>>Reto: Tiny, tiny touch targets.
>>Ian: Yeah, they're really really difficult
to use.
So yeah, basically this is a performance dis-improvement.
>>Reto: Exactly.
This is gonna make it harder for people to,
to do.
I mean, basically, if you've got an app like
this, the intention is gonna be that they
use this instead of their camera app.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: So every time they take a photo, it's
gonna be with this, including from within
other apps.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: So you need to make it at least as
easy to use, as feature complete as the built
in camera app which can be tricky.
But in terms of UI here in particular you
wanna try and make sure that it's easy to
use.
And certainly not harder and slower to use.
>>Ian: Yeah, and again can't emphasize this
enough, especially for apps like camera.
Camera has voice recorders, the timers, anytime
that you're doing something where you may
not actually be looking at the screen closely,
or you may not be concentrating on the UI,
[clunk in background] it's absolutely critical
that you test on some of these newer devices
that have no hard buttons, because if you
look at the camera for- we were are on PicsArt?
>>Reto: We were on Camera FX.
>>Ian: Camera FX, sorry.
If I'm taking a picture, what am I gonna hit?
What button am I gonna hit when I try to take
that picture?
[door closes in background] I'm sorry, we're
apparently getting bossman stopping by here.
>>Reto: Very strange things happening in the
corner of our eyes.
>>Ian: Lot of people.
>>Reto: Not sure why.
>>Ian: Oh Hi, I have no idea who you are.
OK cool.
Let's move on.
>>Reto: Indeed indeed.
So the next thing I wanted to point out was
around, something that you described earlier.
So the hipster filters.
So there's a bunch of ways you can do this
and it's all basically maths and Android actually
has a pretty good tool for making maths work
quickly.
And that is RenderScript.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: And so actually Jeff Sharkey gave
a great presentation at I/O this year, which
included a big section
on how to use RenderScript to perform complicated
computational mathematics.
And in fact, in the example he gave was being
able to start creating hipster filters.
>>Ian: Yep.
And in fact we have a library of them.
>>Reto: Indeed indeed.
And so check this out and that will sort of
help you to get those sort of standard things
and give you the right processes to be able
to create your own more interesting and innovative
filters as well.
>>Ian: There's also some great resources out
there if you're interested in GPU accelerating.
RenderScript will actually use the GPU in
some circumstances but you're always better
off just using openGL if it's something that
the GPU can handle all by itself.
So, one of those two or if you absolutely
must, drop in C and use NEON but that should
be your last resort.
And the reason it should be your last resort
is because there is currently Intel phones
on the market, there's MIPS phones on the
market, you can't guarantee that you're gonna
be running on an ARM device.
You could this year, next year it's anybody's
game.
>>Reto: I think that's one of the advantages
of something like RenderScript is that it
really does all of that for you so it's gonna
to figure out-
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Reto: -the right processor and infrastructure
to take advantage of those –
>>Ian: Yeah you know who wrote RenderScript
is the guys we hired from NVIDIA, they were
on the CUDA
team so-
>>Reto: There ya go.
>>Ian: -they know their stuff.
Alright.
>>Reto: Great, alright so let's move on.
The next piece of advice was around supporting
Picasa.
So I do have- I think most of these apps did,
I think there was one which didn't.
I'll have to refresh my memory-
>>Ian: Well not about Picasa, we're talking
about in general.
>>Reto: Exactly, basically anything which
comes in the gallery is something you can
pick to apply a filter to, I expect that to
work.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: I expect to be able to apply that
filter to any image which comes back now.
>>Ian: So, would it be correct to say then
what we really wanna do is support image providers?
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: Right.
Any image provider which can end up in my
gallery, yeah.
>>Ian: Right, because you know this isn't
just about Picasa.
Picasa is sort of the default because it ships
with the device, but we encourage everybody
to make image providers and-
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Ian: -many OEMs do.
We don't actually ship a Facebook image provider
as part of Android, but many of the different
OEMs you know, Samsung, Motorola they have
their own builds and they have a Facebook
image provider.
>>Reto: Oh nice.
>>Ian: You know, Flickr image provider etcetera,
etcetera.
So you really wanna be able to work with that
so the user doesn't see something in the gallery,
see something that their phone is seamlessly
offering without saying "Oh this is special
because it came from service Provider Y.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: You see it all in a big list and then
if you select one and if it doesn't work,
people are just going to get frustrated by
your app.
>>Reto: Exactly and so that's what you want
to get away from.
Now it turns out this is not entirely a trivial
problem so you really need to, to look at
the URLs the URIs which you get back when
you do the picking action.
I had a quick look online, it turns out we
don't have a great document on how to do this
across sort of the different versions, which
is something we should do.
So, I'm gonna put that to our writing team
and see if we can get something put together.
In the meantime, I did find this blog post,
I haven't validated it in detail, it did look
like it was suggesting the right things, so
you may want to check that out and that will
give you an idea for the right way to do that
for the Picasa at least.
>>Ian: Excellent.
>>Reto: So now the lack of transparency is
gonna bite us.
>>Ian: Yeah, it is.
>>Reto: The other thing which we mentioned
as well is we want these apps to work on all
devices.
Now it turns out after the latest updates,
all of these apps did.
When I tested them last night, a couple did
not appear to be installable on my Nexus 7
but this morning they did.
So thank you-
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Reto: -to those apps which pushed out an
update late last night to make that happen.
But this link below will take you to a blog
post which will tell you exactly how to make
sure that your app does work on devices if
you don’t have a back facing camera.
>>Ian: Now see here is where we missed a QR
code.
>>Reto: Well, that's true.
It's all a learning curve.
>>Ian: Next week.
>>Reto: Next week, exactly.
So definitely do keep that in mind and so
the reason why this is particularly important
for cameras is because there was an assumption
at the very, very, very early days of Android
that every device would have a camera as part
of the compatibility test sweep.
And since that has gradually relaxed over
time to give more opportunities for differences
in hardware, we have had to maintain that
assumption that if you are asking for a camera
permission, that must mean you need a camera
for the device.
And that’s no longer the case.
And so you have to explicitly say hey, I know
that I've asked for the permission to use
the camera, but even if the camera isn't there,
that’s fine I'm still happy to run.
>>Ian: Right, you need to mark that optional
in your manifest and, in addition, one thing
that I personally find very confusing and
I think that maybe other people do too is
remember that camera in this case means a
rear-facing camera.
A front-facing camera is something completely
different.
Which is not a camera.
>>Reto: Yeah, that's totally a different string.
That's front-facing camera, not camera.
I mean, I know that a lot of this stuff is
gonna seem weird and arbitrary but really
it's just there to ensure backwards compatibility.
So where, beforehand camera meant rear-facing
camera, it just didn't say that it meant rear-facing
camera, we can't change the string because
that will break all the apps which have made
that assumption beforehand.
So it can get a little bit confusing but that's
why backwards compatibility is no joke.
So OK, that's basically all of things in terms
of prescriptions and the advice there.
So we've got a couple of minutes because the
next show isn't starting for a half hour.
>>Ian: Yeah, we're doing great, I thought
we were doing an hour today, I mean officially
an hour.
>>Reto: Oh we are, we've got eight minutes.
>>Ian: Alright, well let's get on to the recap
then.
>>Reto: If you think that we're going to finish
off in less than eight minutes, I think you're
sorely mistaken.
>>Ian: Oh lightning round!
>>Reto: [chuckles] So this is the prescriptions,
so we just looked at each of these in more
detail.
So let's take a look at each of the apps specifically
and see how many of these they managed to
do.
Today I have not used green as a way of saying
they've done it.
I've left it in blue so that it doesn't disappear
into our background.
>>Ian: OK
>>Reto: So this is our first app-
>>Ian: Not that this was a problem.
>>Reto: Oh, yeah, but it was hard to see that
that meant good, because it could be any color
based on whatever was behind it.
>>Ian: Quite true.
Alright.
>>Reto: So what they did really well here
they offered the standard unique hipster filters,
they have the community photography which
was really easy and fun to browse through
and it works on devices without cameras so
you can just enjoy looking at photos on whatever
device you happen to have.
What they didn't do was support every image
in the gallery.
So this was the app where when I clicked through
to try to and apply a filter to something
from my gallery, which is all stuck in Picasa,
I got the I can't access this image.
So that would be the number one tip for these
guys would be please do make sure that works.
We're happy to help provide the information
you need to make that happen.
And you know, it does look great without contradiction
the design guide.
I gave that one a yellow just because you
know, like there's a couple of little things
the search bar, the draw pattern, the menu
button, those sorts of things which-
>>Ian: They re-implemented the action bar-
>>Reto: They did.
>>Ian: --which is always tricky because you're
gonna get something wrong, and even if you
get it perfectly right, you're gonna get broken
by the next version.
So hopefully they can move over to you know,
Action Bar Sherlock or Action Bar App Compat
and start using something that Google is supporting
directly and that'll make their app easier
to maintain I think.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So I think this was a great app.
>>Reto: I really liked the look of it.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: I can see why it's so popular.
I think if you add that support for Picasa
or for generic images in the gallery, you're
on to a real winner.
Second app we looked at was PicsArts, again
so this ticked almost all of the boxes.
It supports every image, it offers the standard
and unique hipster filters.
You've got community stuff there.
It works on devices without cameras.
So it's pretty good.
Again, I gave it a yellow against the design
guide, in this case they've done the action
bar correctly, they’ve got the search filters
and everything else.
I think where I got a little more concerned
was around things like the camera which again,
they've got the custom UI, it doesn't seem
to be adding a lot.
>>Ian: And the shutter button is not only
tiny but directly next to the home button
where my thumb will very easily slide over
that.
>>Reto: [chuckles] Very easy to hit.
>>Ian: Very bad idea.
>>Reto: So that’s a concern.
And I also found that once I started sort
of tunneling into this app a little bit more,
it started to get a little more difficult
to navigate and a little harder to understand
what the navigation patterns were, what some
of the user ability stuff was.
So they've done a really good job on the front
page, but it starts to go downhill a little
bit after that.
Once you navigate past that first home screen
in view pager.
>>Ian: Right, but I will say that they did
a great job on their image list.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Ian: They look really really pretty.
>>Reto: That's a great example of the right
way to do that.
Yeah, nicely done.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Reto: Third app was Glimmr.
So this was the Flickr viewer.
So obviously that gets red dots for anything
to do with applying filters because that's
not what this app does.
>>Ian: That's a little unfair.
>>Reto: I was gonna –
>>Ian: Maybe it should be black dot or a white
dot.
>>Reto: I was gonna change them.
I should just remove them.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: Get them out of there cause it's not
really appropriate but- it does look great.
Great looking UI.
It's all about the community of photographers.
It works on any device.
Again, it's a much more simple app than some
of the others we looked at today but they've
done a really good job with what they've got.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
Alright.
>>Reto: and last off we looked at Camera ZOOM
FX.
So this didn't have the community photography,
it didn't have that ability to see other photos
that people have taken with the great app
and I don't know, I like it if for no other
reason than it shows you what's possible with
a camera phone and with their app.
So it's kinda great advertising for your own
app if you have that in there.
And similarly the design guide issues were
a little bit questionable in terms of how
much value are you adding by creating this
new skin for your- for your camera.
Really small icons a little bit blurry.
So I think they can do a little bit there
to make it a much better app.
So that's all.
That's all we wanted to look at in terms of
apps today.
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Reto: We've got I think, three or four minutes
left to go.
>>Ian: Woohoo.
>>Reto: Which is nice.
We are going to pass on each of the apps we've
looked at today to the guys, to Roman, Nick,
and Adam, to look at in Android Design in
Action on Tuesday at ten thirty.
So definitely check that out.
I'm not sure which apps they're planning on
to look at today, it will be amongst those
four.
But keep an eye on the Android Developers
Plus page, we'll announce exactly which apps
those are hopefully later today.
>>Ian: Absolutely, and once again join us
next Thursday when Developers Strike Back
against both Reto, myself, and Roman and his
crew and see what they think of the suggestions,
criticisms and potentially new designs-
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Ian: -that we've suggested to them.
>>Reto: So make sure, if you are one of the
developers we talked about today, do make
sure we have a way to get in contact with
you so we can invite you to the show.
If you are one of our viewers and you have
questions for the developers, again let us
know in the comments to the events to the
Gplus event and we'll be sure to put those
questions to the developers when we have them
live via Hangout in the studio.
>>Ian: Now if you're a game developer or you
like games or you like beer or you're bedridden
and you just have nothing else to do, don't
forget that the Friday Games Review is happening
today and has also moved to another time.
We're doing that at noon Pacific so in just
about half an hour, Daniel Galpin and myself-
>>Reto: Excellent.
>>Ian: -will be doing that.
I will change from my lab coat into my hoodie.
We'll get down, we'll get jiggy, we'll do
game stuff.
>>Reto: I'm concerned that you went the Redbull
during the wrong show.
>>Ian: You think maybe?
>>Reto: I think maybe you did.
Maybe that's when the Mountain Dew's coming
out.
I dunno.
>>Ian: You don't even know, I'm like- I'm
kicking it Elvis style, alright?
>>Reto: Oh wow.
>>Ian: This is the- you gotta get right in
the middle.
>>Reto: Yeah, sure.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Reto: Alright nice.
>>Daniel: I think maybe you guys are gonna
match levels, I think it's less about getting
a Redbull for yourself and maybe getting a
Valium for Neil.
>>Reto: That's true-
>>Ian: That might be true.
>>Reto: That might be-
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Reto: So that's pretty much it for us.
We are going to look at travel booking and
planning apps in the App Clinic.
>>Ian: Absolutely right.
We're getting ready for the holidays so we
figure everybody travels during the holiday.
>>Reto: Pretty much.
>>Ian: Either to be with family or to get
away from family.
So-
>>Reto: True that.
>>Ian: -it's about time to start booking those
flights.
We're gonna look at booking apps and then
later on, we're going to look at travel apps
as in apps to help you when you're on the
road.
So-
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: -make sure that get right.
>>Reto: So your currency converters etcetera
later.
For tomorrow- for next week we wanna have
apps which help you make bookings help you
figure out where to go, those sorts of things.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Reto: So yeah, definitely give us your suggestions
on the moderator page and tune in same time
as this week, next week.
This is gonna be the new time unless it turns
out that we've been talking to an audience
of three, when we may reconsider.
That's pretty much it from us.
Thank you very much for joining us at the
new time and thank you for everyone who nominated
apps and voted for them.
Without that we would have a pretty boring
show, or at least perhaps more boring than
it already is.
>>Ian: Alright.
>>Reto: My name's Reto Meier.
>>Ian: I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Reto: And we will see you all next week.
>>Ian: See ya.